- Guys, we did it.
- I don't think I can
go to another wedding.
- Hey guys, come on, we
have two more, alright?
- And then, wedding season is over. Over.
(phone rings)
Got a phone call.
Hey, cousin Roberto, what's up?
- (sigh) What a season.
- Oh, hey, look at that. Go USA!
- [Phone] Quinta, guess
what. I'm getting married!
- You're getting married? That's awesome!
Congratulations! I'm so happy for you.
- [Phone] Yes yes. You must
come to my wedding, love.
You have to be there.
- Uh, yeah, um, of course
I'll come to your wedding.
- Justin, how many gay friends do we have?
(muttered counting)
- [Phone] There will be a big wedding,
the reception, the second reception
- How many celebrations are you having?
- That's double the weddings!
- So, wait, in how many different cities?
- [Phone] Only three. Four
including Ohio, for his family.
Wait, five including mine.
It's gonna be so great.
(dramatic music)
- It's not over.
- I'm gonna stick out
like a straight white male
at a gay man's wedding!
- We have to go to 47 weddings
in the next two months!
Oh no. It's 48.
- (shouting) Oh God!
- Not only are you guys
invited to the wedding.
Quinta, I want you to be my bridesmaid.
And Justin, I want you to be my bridesman.
- I have to be a bridesmaid
in double the weddings.
Double the weddings!
- (muttering) Double the
weddings. Double the weddings.
- I cannot take a gay
man's bachelor party.
- The macarenas challenge
me with these people!
- It's all about the YMCA now.
(shouting)
- I'm gonna go broke. Broke!
- Alright, so I took care of the present.
- Give me that.
- No!
- This is Sunbeam, Zach.
You went to Target?
- Williams-Sonoma is too expensive!
(shouting)
Why is this happening?
(eerie music)
- [Group] We're friends.
Til death do us part.
(upbeat trumpet music)
(screams)
- Oh my God, it's just our
neighbor Christian. What's up?
- Oh nothing. Where you
guys headed, so fancy?
- Just going to a wedding.
- It's our friends Nathaniel and Steve.
- I'm sorry. Did you say Nathan and,
it sounded like you said Steve.
I mean that, I know, would be a,
unnatural.
- Run. He's a conservative, run!
(upbeat trumpet music)